Oh,
>> hello. Good to see you again. Okay.
>> Yep. You, too. Hey, Avery.
>> Good, man. How you doing? How you been
all week?
>> Uh, I've been hanging in there, you
know, and just living my life.
>> It's good, man. It's good. What's on
your mind?
>> Uh, so actually, um, I was hoping we
could pick up where we left off when we
were talking about uh, you know, mocker
and the the Quran versus I think 354 and
and the one in Surah 4, I believe. And
so, um, I was trying to tell you that,
um, that the mocker, um, that was
orchestrated by God is different
compared to how human beings might lie
for evil gains essentially. And
>> oh, you're talking about Allah being the
deceiver, right?
>> Um, well, see, I don't think so. Um, I
was actually reading the taps by Iban
Kafir, and he used the word deceived as
part of his taps. But um I've seen
translations like um the best of those a
plot or a planning. And so I've actually
managed to formulate I guess uh an ide
sorry an analogy to explain that verse.
So imagine we got an arsonist and
someone who does controlled burning. So
controlled burning is something that's
acceptable to manage a fire, but an
arsonist is someone that might carry out
an arson to try to to take lives. And so
God um using his plotting to outsmart
the um the uh the uh the Jews that were
um full of themselves and or looking to
prove Jesus to be false. They got
punished by thinking they were executing
Jews but really weren't. And so and also
um uh I know that there are um three
cases where a person is I guess
permitted uh to lie and any Muslim can
tell you it's like you know during uh
the during a battle um to bring peace
between people and to and like like a
spouse making up with their significant
other.
Um uh God is um described as all
powerful and all just and we there are
some things about him that we can't know
too like 100% about him given his his
power.
>> And so um I would say that um that God
had a purpose in essentially tricking um
uh tricking the um the Jews that that
thought they were uh executing Jesus but
really weren't. So, let me let me just
clarify something. Are you saying that
lying is okay if it if it brings out
about a greater good? Is that what
you're getting at?
>> Well, again, um any Muslim can tell you
that there are only three cases where it
is halal for a Muslim uh to lie, which
is, you know, during war uh spouse
making up with like their significant
other and to bring peace uh between
people. But the a type of lying that is
bad is let's say like someone clearly
saw me throw somebody across the room
and and I still lie about them and and
try to gaslight them. That's not that's
not an acceptable type of lying and that
would actually be a major sin.
>> And I did already draw that an analogy
about an arsonist and a controlled
controlled burning. Controlled burning
is supposed to be it's an approved
tactic to manage fires, but an arsonist
tries to um claim lives and destroy
property. And so, uh like a liar, um who
tries to um stow division or uh tries to
gaslight somebody is just all they're
doing is just um using it for evil gains
and um will bring everybody including
themselves down a dark path.
>> Yeah. So, that's why I clarified. So
using your analogy of the controlled
burn and the arsenic, you're saying that
lying in Islam could be good if it
brings about a greater good. Like and
then it's bad if it if you know if it
doesn't. So like a controlled burn you
you could burn some things. You could
say an analogously that's a little bad,
but it's bringing about a greater good
preventing a forest fire. So that that's
what I was asking. Is that what you're
trying to get out with your analogy?
Well, it really depends on what is
happening and it really it all varies
upon the situation but um but it really
depends on what good you are talking
about and so um but there are you there
you really should try to look for
alternatives to that if feasible but
>> yeah but yeah but but Islam is all about
like Islam says that you know God knows
your intentions and he's all
understanding and so I think that and
like he he knows everyone's hearts And
so that I suspect that's why he made
those three exceptions for us.
>> Okay. But then could are you saying
Allah can lie if it brings about a
greater good?
>> Where are you going?
>> Well, that's what Sigati said last time
on the stream after you left. That's
what he was arguing with another Muslim.
Are you agreeing with like Sidati on
that?
>> Well, see see this is what I'm getting
at here. So, um, like when a when like
when a when an evil person lies, they're
obviously trying to stow division and
cause obvious destruction. But God's
counter scheming when when the when the
Jews apparently believe they were
executing Jesus was a way to keep
Jesus's name as a prophet intact and to
keep the truth uh intact.
>> Well, it sounds like we're saying the
same thing. I I mean you're you're
you're you're saying like so in your
analogy you're saying yeah the the Jews
were scheming so Allah so they were
trying to deceive so Allah deceived them
back because that brought about a
greater good is what that seems what
you're saying and I'm just trying to
make make sure that we're on the same
page. So I think I actually know I know
a way to explain this. So um let's say
um you know you're communicating with an
atheist and they ask you you know how
could God flood the whole world yet
condemn murder at the same time? Like
what would you say to that atheist?
Yeah, I would say that murder for
example, a person is uh it's killing an
innocent life,
>> right?
>> And of course in that example according
to the flood account, there was no
innocent life. God can bring judgment
upon sinful people. So yeah, we would
not say killing is necessarily wrong. Uh
ending a life justly can be a good
thing. And that's I that's why again I
think we're on the same page here. I'm
just trying to make sure we are.
>> Okay. Yeah. The reason why I asked you
that is because like there is so just as
there's a difference between a person
killing another person which is which
obviously is trying to spread corruption
and wreak havoc and so you said that
like you know God flooding the world was
was apparently disciplined to those that
were sinning and even and they and Noah
even tried to reason with the people yet
they ignored him. And so I believe that
um when those Jews were apparently they
they thought they were trying to execute
Jesus like they were full of themselves.
They were trying to apparently show
everyone that you know Jesus wasn't
really a prophet when he really was. And
so
>> okay I'm with you. I'm with you. So
yeah.
>> Are you saying Allah can deceive if it
brings about a greater good?
>> If you apply in a certain context I
would say sure.
>> Okay. So if Allah deceived the Jews in
the world by putting someone to look
like Jesus on the cross who wasn't him,
what greater good did that bring about
given that it created the world's
largest competitor to Islam, created
constant division between the Islamic
and the Christian world, resulting in
thousands of battles, killing,
enslavement, you know, tit fortat, all
that nonsense. How did that bring about
a greater good in that in that regard?
Again, like the thing I've been trying
to get at with you is that when like
those Jews when they were apparently
killing the lookalike Jesus, they
thought we're going to finally prove to
everyone that he was lying and so we're
going to show everyone what a fraud he
was. And so God decid decided that I'm
not going to let my prophet go through
this. I'm going to take him up into
heaven alive. And so apparently and and
also I think another comparison I could
make is let's say um like the owner of a
building decides to sneak a hidden
camera to to to catch an unknown
criminal and in the act and he thinks I
got away with this. This is awesome. But
no, he really didn't. And so yeah, and
so I would say that um um that uh we we
can't there are things that we can't
understand about God's justice yet we
put our faith in him. And so, um, I
would say that that was just a
punishment to a specific group of
people, um, and in the process keeping
Jesus's name as a prophet intact.
>> Couldn't Allah just have taken Jesus up
like he took Elijah up without having
someone die on the cross and start
Christianity?
>> Well, see, yeah. I mean,
>> you do make a fair point there, but I'm
referring to a very specific case where
it was a a small group of Jews who if
they were they refused to trust Jesus no
matter what, even after he tried to talk
to them and reason with him. And so when
they were all like, "Oh yeah, we're
going to finally prove to everyone that
he was a big fraud or whatever." And so,
um, and so, uh, again, uh, God taking
Jesus up into paradise alive was awaited
to for God to protect him. and to punish
the sinners in the process.
>> So then how did having a companion or
disciple of Jesus or someone being made
to appear so that he got crucified help
that? I I mean he could just have taken
Jesus up like Elijah was taken up. Why
did he also need to have somebody die on
the cross who appeared as Jesus and then
start the world's largest religion which
competes with Islam? So sometimes like
even like I'm like a little bit tripped
up about like this um idea in the Quran
like which I I do I I do like believe
what that verse says in the Quran about
him not being uh crucified but I've
heard answers like oh maybe one of the
disciples willingly decided to take on
his appearance to trick everybody or
maybe it was Simon or maybe it was just
a whole another person that everybody
believed was Jesus when he really
>> all this conjecture man all this
conjecture that you have to follow in
order to hold this position instead of
where all the evidence leads that Jesus
was crucified.
>> I mean, I get I get what you're doing,
man, but the way it let me just try to
get explain the way it looks to people
else. It looks like we're starting with
a conclusion. Islam has got to be true.
There can't be a mistake. Now, I have to
come up with conjecture to make it fit.
And the problem we see with that is that
is just not how we would do anything.
Like let's say let's say like we were
scientists and we discovered electricity
and I was I was a believer in alchemy
and you were like we discovered
electricity. I'm like no no no yeah it
looks like we create electricity really
these are the magical wizards in
parallel dimensions are shooting lasers
into our dimension. You'd look at me
like okay yeah possibly but that's
that's not the simplest explanation. The
simplest explanation is electricity. And
likewise, when it comes to this, the
simplest explanation is Jesus was
crucified. The Quran got it wrong. And
if if if Allah did make someone appear
to look like Jesus, I don't see how that
kind of deceiving leads to something
good. And that's the problem we see.
>> So actually uh I actually found the uh
taps written by Iben Kafir concerning
this verse. And so I'm just going to go
ahead and read off of it right now. So
it says, "The Jews plot to kill Jesus."
And so God states that the children of
Israel tried to kill Jesus by conspiring
to defame him and crucify him. They
complained about him to the king who was
a disbeliever. They claimed that Jesus
was a man who misguided people,
discouraged them from obeying the king,
caused division, and separated between
man and his own son. They also said
other lies about Jesus which they will
carry on their necks, including accusing
him of being an illegitimate son. The
king became furious and sent his men to
capture Jesus to torture and crucify
him. when they surround Jesus's home and
he thought that they would surely
capture him, God saved him from there uh
from their uh from their raising him up
from the house to heaven. God put the
image of Jesus on a man who was in the
house when the unjust people went into
the house when it was still dark. They
thought he was Jesus. They then captured
that man, humiliated and crucified him.
They also placed thorns on his head.
However, God deceived these people. He
saved and raised his profit from them,
leaving them in disarray in the darkness
of their transgression, thinking that
they had successfully achieved their
goal. God made their hearts hard and
defiant of the truth, disgracing them in
such disgrace that it will remain with
them until the day of resurrection. This
is why God said, "And they plotted, and
God plotted, too, and God is the best of
those who plot." Now, again, yeah. Yeah.
And uh going back to that little
comparison I made about how um you have
um an arsonist who wants to just destroy
property and possibly even take some
lives in the process against control
burns which have been our approved
technique which are which is 100% safe
and is a way to to keep it safe. And so
uh yeah as I read in the tough sear
these were people who were full of
themselves. they were boastful and they
wanted to they wanted apparently to show
everyone what a fraud he was. And so
that I guess was uh I guess God's way of
protecting his prophet from that
disgrace and humiliation and to keep the
prophetic message safe.
>> So question like you're at a school
right now, right?
>> I sure am.
>> Yeah. Let's say like, you know, you were
trapped in the school and there was a
mob, a woke mob outside that school that
wanted to get the Muslim, but I was on a
SWAT team and I came through the window
above you. I pulled you up, but I also
had a magic wand and I said, "Don't
worry. I'm going to turn your friend
right there look like you. They're going
to kill him." And then I took you up
into the helicopter. Would you be happy
with that? That I just now made your
friend is going to get killed by this
woke mob or you would you be a little
pissed at me for that? Well,
>> oh man, that is I like that comparison.
I might think about that some more, but
uh yeah, but yeah, but let's not forget
that only God is the one who is all know
all knowing, all powerful, and all just.
And so, you you know, we we are both
commanded to have faith in his plan
essentially. And so, um yeah, that's
what I got to say about that.
>> Yeah, the the one thing we'd say in
Christianity is that God makes a
covenant and he doesn't go back on his
word. So when he says, "I'm going to use
you, Abraham, to bless the nations," he
doesn't go back on that. And I was just
reading some historians past month. They
said, "This actually gave rise to modern
science because God made a covenant and
he keeps his word so we can trust it."
If we've got a God like Allah who
deceives and goes back on his word. That
doesn't sound like a good God to me.
That sounds like somebody who just
willy-nilly changes mind one day and and
it's like this is this is this this
brings up some issues. Well, let let's
just let's let's think about that. You
said you want to think about it, you
know, go. But is there something else
you wanted to talk about because we
talked about a lot of things last week.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah, sure. Um, see, I do have
a Google doc. Let me see if I can find
it. Okay. Oh, yeah. Um, I figured we
talk about
um, yeah, here let's talk about um, so I
think I told you last stream that David
Wood says that what would make him a
Muslim is is proof that the Quran says
that the text of the Jews and the
Christians has been corrupted. I figured
we can let's let's go there. And so I
have been preparing some things
recently. And so hold on before we get
get into it. Have you heard of Zakernik
and Admida?
>> Have we ever?
>> Yeah. And so, um, they both issued a
challenge to all the Christians saying
if they can show him a verbatim 100%
statement in any version of the Bible
where Jesus himself says that he's God,
where he says to pray to him, then
they're ready to be Christians. So,
okay, now let's get right into it right
away. And so, the way David Wood's exact
phrase statement on the Quran
differentiates from Zucker's demand is
this. And so if you take it at face
value, they argue from explicit
statements to challenge an opponent's
theological position. And so um if Jesus
being God is a central uh essential
doctrine of salvation that it must be
said by Jesus himself, not simply
referred to by like a second person like
Paul or somebody else. And so that claim
is extraordinary. Requires direct
explicit evidence from the person
himself, not postfactual
interpretations. And so Muslims do not
claim that the Quran says that the angel
was textually corrupted verbatim.
Rather, the Quran says that the past
scriptures given to the Jews and the
Christians uh were they were uh altered
by people which needed the Quran to get
involved. And so surah 279 says
something along the lines of like woe to
those who tamper with his word. And so
this comes from not one but multiple
verses which have contextual and scarly
consensus as opposed to one mere phrase.
And so yeah of course the Quran does not
need to say that the gospel is textually
corrupted. Um just says it does not need
to say alcohol is haram verbatim but
states pro prohibition clearly in surah
590.
And so I actually have a comparison to
make um uh about this. And so,
>> well, you know, hurry up. You've been
gone for a little while. Then we'd like
to respond.
>> Sure.
>> Averyy's going to Avery's He's getting
ready.
>> Get your hands off me.
>> Oh, man.
>> So,
>> is this is this the Islamic dilemma? Cuz
I was kind of getting
>> kind of
>> Okay. I was I was about to say my shadow
for a second. I was in a days.
>> Okay. So, so just summarize for me what
your main point is. What?
>> Okay. So what I what I said again was
that um it h so um in order to meet
Zucker's challenge it has to be
something from Jesus himself not simply
uh an author like Paul or somebody who
came
>> so you need you need Jesus claiming to
be God
>> saying that in those exact words. Yes.
>> In those exact words.
>> Yes. That's what he says is part of a
challenge.
>> So wait is is this challenge valid? I
would say so because he's demanding it
be it be from Jesus himself.
>> Okay. So do you do you think that it's
important like it will be an essential
and important um teaching of Jesus that
if people are getting this idea that he
is God or worshiping him that he comes
out and explicitly says hey I am not God
don't worship me. Well, see, the thing
is is that like, you know, most like
most of the Christians I've encountered
will tell you that, but I'm just simply
saying um like they they have to write
some type of verse to to justify that.
>> They'll tell you that he's God.
>> Yes, that's what I'm getting at there.
>> Okay. So, but I'm talking about for for
Jesus, you're saying for Jesus to be
God,
>> this would be something that he would
have to explicitly say in the exact
words, I am God, in order for him to be
God.
>> Right. That's where I'm getting.
>> So, all right. So, I'm I'm asking the
reverse. So, that means the reverse is
true that if he's not God, then he would
have to teach explicitly in the exact
words, I am not God. Right.
>> Well, but um there are like verses which
hint at him giving a prophetic message.
>> Remember, you said it has to be in the
exact words or else he ain't he's not
claiming to be God. So, I'm saying the
same thing reverse. Same standard, same
criteria, just the reverse. If Jesus is
clear in teaching that he's not God,
then he would have to come out and say
the exact words, "I am not God. Do not
worship me." Right.
>> H uh
yeah, I would say that that is um I see
where you're going with that. And so um
okay, now I would like to continue on
with
>> Wait, wait, wait. We got to we got to we
got to make sure I'm glad you see the
point. Now let's let's make sure that we
that we settle this now. So with that
being said, do you think that that is a
fair and good challenge? Is that a good
challenge to demand that Jesus says the
words, "I am God, worship me." And then
therefore, is it also fair of us to then
also demand the same thing, just the
reverse? Show us where Jesus says, "I am
not God. Do not worship me."
>> Um,
I would not say so. But the reason I'm
bringing that up is I'm just simply I'm
I would just simply say to the
Christian, look, I mean, you're the one
that claims to believe in the truth. So,
I'm just simply asking them to to
somehow justify that position. That's
all.
>> Yeah. And same same for me. You're
you're the one telling me Jesus is not
God. He's just a mere prophet. So, show
me where Jesus says, I am not God. I'm
just a mere prophet.
>> Right. I I can ask the same type of I
can ask I can apply the same standard to
you can't I
>> actually I am able to give you a verse
which says that Jesus is a prophet
>> that's not what I'm asking for remember
same standard I'm asking for where Jesus
says in his exact word these exact words
I am not God I am just a prophet
>> well I I guess you are right that
nowhere in the Bible does it also it
also doesn't say he's not God either but
I am able to show you a verse verse
where he where it says that Jesus is
called a prophet. I can show you to I
can I can read right now.
>> That's beautiful. And I can show you a
verse where Jesus is called God.
>> I can show you a verse where Jesus says
he's God.
>> So yeah, uh Matthew 21:11 says, "This is
a prophet Jesus from Nazareth in
Galilee." And John 4:19, it says, "Sir,
I perceive you are a prophet." And Luke
13:33
says, "It cannot be a prophet would
perish outside of Jerusalem." And Mark
6:4 says, "A prophet is not without
honor except in his hometown."
>> So the word prophet appeared in each of
these verses.
>> That's good. Yeah. Nice.
>> Okay. Now,
>> can we can we show you the other way?
>> Yeah, you can go.
>> See what you what you just what you just
did. And what's your name, brother?
>> Okay. Well, my birth name is Nick, but
my my username is Muslim and Gen Z.
>> Muslim and Gen Z.
>> Yes.
>> Can I call you Nick?
>> Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> All right, Nick. So, um, what you just
did is that you just you just did a very
beautiful job at proving that Jesus is a
prophet.
>> Mhm.
>> Beautiful job. You gave us nice, good
verses that proves without a shadow of a
doubt that Jesus is a prophet. And
anybody who says that he's not a
prophet, they are among the wrongdoers.
They're going against what the Bible
teaches and against what Jesus teaches.
>> Now, we're also going to show you that
he's not merely a prophet. Yes, he's a
prophet and and he is God. That's what
we're going to show you. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> All right. So, here's some for just just
talking about some claims here. Uh for
example, cuz if we're just sticking with
the the forer writings of the gospel
authors here, or if we're just sticking
with you sticking with Jesus's words,
just Jesus himself, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. cuz it sound like you quoted
somebody else that said I I perceived
you to be to be a prophet, right?
>> So, okay. Again, and so um that so um
and oh come on, let me just so Jesus
identified himself as a prophet
apparently in Luke 13:33 and people also
refer to him as a prophet all the other
verses.
>> Got it. So I So what we're going to do
is we're going to give you the same
thing you gave us where Jesus identifies
himself as God and where somebody else
identifies him as God. Okay? So, I I'll
work backwards. I'll show you where
somebody identified him as God. This is
just one of many examples. Okay. Go to
John chapter 20.
>> John chapter 20, right?
>> Thanks.
>> Uh, so it's John 5:20, right?
>> Nope. John chapter 20.
>> John chapter 20. What's the verse?
>> It'll be verse 28.
>> Okay. It's It's coming. Okay. So, Okay.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. I was going to say I've
heard about that verse before. And so I'
I've seen this all over social media
where Christians try to cite that verse
to make it seem as though he's uh a
divine. And so Thomas was the one that
actually quoted that. And so from a from
my perspective, I have to examine this
carefully because you know, Islam says
that Jesus is a prophet. And so
apparently um Thomas was he was talking
to him and using a he was apparently
voicing astonishment. Um and so in
biblical Greek, let me just read it for
you. Wait, Voicing astonishment to who?
>> He was talking to Jesus voicing and
using of astonishment as opposed to
declaring him as mine. And and let me
just
>> That's not that's not what the Jews did
at all. That would be blasphemy.
>> Okay. And also um
and and also let's not forget that the
New Testament was written by humans
sometime after.
>> But you just quoted the you just quoted
the New Testament to prove Jesus was a
prophet. So let's not do this now. You
just used the New Testament to prove
Jesus was a prophet. So, I'm going to
use that same New Testament to prove
that he's also God. You can't say that
now that I'm showing where Jesus is God
that now it's corrupted. You can't do
that, bro.
>> It's not fair.
>> That That's the Muslim tactic, man. I'm
trying to drag you out of that. Before
you go full Muslim, I'm telling you,
before you go full Muslim, you It
doesn't seem like you got got yet.
Before you go full This is what the
Muslim would do. The Muslim will quote
to me the New Testament to help their
case. And then when I show the New
Testament that defeats their case,
they'll say, "Oh, well that's
corrupted." You don't want to be that
guy because that looks crazy.
>> Well, also, um, actually surah 548 does
say that the Quran is the is the uh is
the ultimate authority. And so what
supports the Quran is good, but what
doesn't you can just throw away. That
seems like what it's telling you to do.
>> All right, we can get into that next.
Okay, we we'll get into that next on
whether or not Allah says that you can
pick and choose what you believe of the
of the of the scriptures. Uh we we'll
talk about that next. But first, let's
talk about the claims of Jesus and the
people around him in the Bible and then
we'll talk about what the Quran's view
is. Okay. Is that fair?
>> Uh sure.
>> All right. So, according to the Bible
here, Thomas calls Jesus his Lord and
his God. Is that correct?
>> It seems to me that that's what it's
saying.
>> So, we got somebody acknowledging and
recognizing Jesus not just as his Lord,
but as his God. Right. Okay. So that's
one of his original 12 disciples that's
doing that. Now Jesus doesn't rebuke
him. He says, "Blessed are I mean you
see that you believe this cuz you see
me, but blessed are those who believe
without seeing." So Jesus affirms what
Thomas is saying about him. He doesn't
deny him or reject him. Right. Go ahead
and read the next verse.
>> Um what verse are you talking about?
>> In John 20:28. Read verse 29.
>> Oh, John 20:29. Right. So, this is right
after Thomas just said, "Just call Jesus
his Lord and his God." Watch how Jesus
responds to him.
>> Okay? And so, um, again, it says, "Jesus
says to him, because you have seen me,
you have believed. Blessed are those who
have not seen yet have believed."
>> So, do you see how he's not reprimanding
Thomas for blasphemy, for calling him
his Lord and God, but he's saying,
"Thomas, you believe this cuz you see
me. But blessed are those who believe
without even having to see me.
>> Who believe what? That he is Lord and
God. That he's risen.
>> So um yeah, John 20:29
is talking about how um it says like to
emphasize like faith in in God like in
his messengers even without I guess
direct visual evidence.
>> Faith in who though?
>> And so Jesus's statement here is that
belief doesn't require seeing miracles
firsthand.
>> But faith in who? Uh
>> I would imagine it's referring to um
referring to Jesus. Right.
>> Exactly. So Jesus is saying put your
faith in me as your Lord and God even
without seeing without having to see it
with your own eyes without having to
visually and physically experience that.
But put your faith in me and believe
that I am your Lord. I am your God.
Believe this without even having to see
and you'll be blessed.
>> See? So Jesus affirms what Thomas is
saying. You understand what I'm saying?
>> I do believe I know where you're going
with this.
>> So, this this is this is Jesus. Right
after Thomas declares Jesus to be God,
Jesus agrees with Thomas that he's his
Lord and God, but says, "Blessed are
those who believe this without even
having to see me."
>> Um, pretty good, huh?
>> Okay. And so, um, yeah. And so, um, I
was actually I actually wanted to
continue reading on what I was going to
say it was. And so, so for
>> Do you want to see where Jesus says we
could pray to him?
>> Wait, sorry, what was the question?
>> Do you want to see where Jesus says we
can pray to him?
>> Where does it say that?
>> Yeah. So, go to John chapter 14. Now,
before before I bring this up, we agree
that prayer is supplication, sending
requests up to God. Right.
>> Right.
>> Okay. So, yeah, go to John chapter 14
and you're going to read verses 12 to
14. John chapter 14.
>> Okay.
>> Verses 12 to 14. So this is going to be
in context of Jesus leaving, going away,
going to heaven.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, okay. It says, uh,
verily I verily truly I tell you,
whoever believes in me will do the works
I've been doing, and they will do even
greater things than these cuz I'm I'm
going to the Father, and I'll ask you
what you do in my name, so that the
Father may be glorified uh in the Son,
and you may ask me for anything in my
name, and I'll do it. So you see that
Jesus just said, "Hey guys, I'm about to
go away. I'm going back to the Father.
And as I'm gone, those who believe will
be able to do even greater works than
than these, right? In quantity, not
quality. In quantity, they're going to
be doing more miracles because Jesus was
only here for 3 years. They're here for
much longer. So they'll be doing
miracles much longer than he did. So
it's greater than quantity, not
quality." Now, here's the point, though.
He's going away to the father and he
says while he's gone he says ask
anything in my name and I will do it. He
says truly I say to you if you ask me
anything in my name I will do it. So
Jesus is saying while he's gone while
he's in heaven with the father we can
supplicate to him. We can send our
requests to Jesus. Supplicate to Jesus.
And not only will he hear our
supplication, but he is going to answer
our prayer. He can answer our requests.
>> So, okay. And so, um, so greater works
could simply mean like the spread of the
message to the entire world. And, um,
let's also not forget that Muslims don't
pray to prophets, but in his name could
simply refer to um, praying with faith
in God as the source while trusting in
the prophets. God
>> because who does he say to ask? Verse
14.
>> Well, it says says, "If you ask me for
anything in my name, I'll do it."
>> So, who's who are we asking?
>> It's referring to Jesus.
>> So, we're asking Jesus in whose name?
Whose authority?
>> In his authority.
>> In his authority. So, he says, "Ask me
in my name." And who's going to answer
the prayer for us?
>> Uh, he will.
>> Exactly. So, we he can hear our prayers,
receive our prayers, and answer our
prayers. We can direct our prayers to
him. He says,
>> "Doesn't this show that he's God?"
>> Well, let's also let's not forget that
miracles came from God, not the prophet
himself. And so, the Quran says that he
performed miracles by God's permission.
>> But does the Quran say that we can pray
to a prophet?
>> Well, it says it says not the opposite.
>> Exactly. So, it says the opposite.
Meaning Jesus here, supposedly just a
prophet, is telling us we can pray to
him. So, is Jesus claiming to be a mere
prophet or is he also claiming to be
God?
>> Well, asking in his name means to trust
in his guidance and teachings faithfully
and acknowledging him as a messenger.
>> Nick,
>> no. Come on, man. Asking him in his
name, who's going to do it?
>> Well, uh well, it says the verse says
that he will.
>> There's no way around it. So is Jesus
claiming to be a mere prophet or is he
also claiming to be God who can answer
our prayers?
>> Seems to be hinting at possible
divinity.
>> Mhm. I love your honesty, brother. So
here we have Jesus. Now we don't see the
words, I am God. Worship me. I am God.
Pray to me. We don't need that. Just
like we don't see the words, I am not
God. Do not worship me. However, what we
do see, Nick, is we see very clear
statements of Jesus claiming to be
divine, claiming to be God in different
ways like this, saying that we can pray
to him and he can answer. Now, let me
let let's think of it this way too,
Nick. Jesus says, Am I boring you?
>> No. Oh, okay. Jesus says Jesus Jesus
says here, watch. He says, "Ask me
anything in my name and I will do it."
So what type of attribute this is
showing that he's going to be able to
hear all the prayers from anyone all the
believers who's who's requesting up to
him. So he has to be all hearing to be
able to even hear all the prayers. He
has to be all knowing. Then it says in
my name. So he has the authority the
power to to be prayed to. And he says I
will do it. My question is this Nick
think about this. What type of attribute
would Jesus have to have to be able to
grant any request that the believer asks
of him? What kind of what what amount of
power would he have to have to be able
to do anything they ask?
>> Well, okay. And so, um, but again, I I
did already say that prayers and works
happen through God, not independent of
him.
>> That's why Jesus is God. That's the
point. That is it. Yep. That's the
point. Jesus is God, which is why their
prayers can be answered when they ask
him. And for him to be able to do
anything that they ask, what kind of
power does he have to have to be able to
do anything they ask? What kind of power
is that? You have to be all powerful,
right?
>> Yes. You would need to be all powerful
for that.
>> Yep. So Jesus is claiming to be all
powerful. He's claiming to be all
hearing, which by default means you're
all knowing. He's claiming to have all
power and authority so that we have we
can send our supplication to him in his
name. So in his authority and his power
and he can do it. So he's claiming to be
all knowing, all hearing and all
powerful and not limited to space for
the believers. They're going to be all
over the earth spread everywhere, right?
Millions of people, billions of people
believing in Jesus, praying to him in
their different languages, wherever they
are, in their different times, in their
different countries and spaces. Meaning
Jesus will have to be omnipresent
to be able to hear all and to be able to
answer all wherever they are. To be able
to answer and grant any request of a
believer in whatever the language is, in
whatever the country is, in whatever the
time zone is, he has to be all knowing,
all powerful and omnipresent. Tell me,
what kind of being, Nick, is all
knowing, all hearing, all powerful and
omnipresent? What kind of being is that?
>> Well, that would have to be God.
>> So, right here, brother, we got Jesus
very clearly claiming to be God,
>> which is John 2021.
>> John 14 John 14
12-4 where he says, "You can ask me
anything in my name and I will do it."
>> Wow. Um,
wow. That's uh seems like a fair point
there and uh I'd be more than happy to
check it out later and uh get back to
you guys on that. Um
>> yeah, that's smart. That's smart and
that's honest. That's humble.
>> Okay. Um
>> uh yeah, I don't think there's anything
else at this time I feel like bring up
now. So I guess um hold on. When are you
guys doing another live stream? Do you
know?
>> I'm live every Monday, Wednesday, and
Friday. usually around the same time
that I started today.
>> IP, when are you going live?
>> Oh, Siguati. Uh I think we'll be live
again September 30th. Uh after my eye
surgery,
uh because I have to get that the prior
week, so we can't do it that week. But I
September 30th, which is a Tuesday, we
should go live like 100 p.m. PST around
that time. It'll be late. So,
>> do you know when you're going live,
Michael?
>> Yeah. September 30th with Sigati. That's
when we're do it. Um, okay. Yeah, I'll
keep an eye on that. And, uh, Avery, and
do you know when you're going live next
or not?
>> Yeah. Uh, what's today? I I'll be
Thursday. I'll be I'll be live tomorrow.
I'll be live tomorrow 2 p.m. uh, Pacific
time, PST.
>> So, you said Monday, Wednesday.
>> Monday. Yep. Monday, Wednesday, and
Friday.
>> 5 p.m.
>> Yep. 5:00 PM Eastern Standard Time. And
also um something I like to bring up is
there is a Muslim apologist I've been
conversing with recently and he says
he'd be willing to to have a formal
debate with anybody on any topic. And so
I think what you can do is find a way to
get in contact with him. Like you can
comment on one of his videos and
>> what's his name?
>> It's Nadir Ahmed and he has a small
YouTube channel.
>> Nadir Akmed.
>> Yes,
>> bro. No,
dick.
>> There's history there. Yeah, there's
there's a lot of history behind Nadir
Ahmed and um
>> you guys already know him.
>> Yes, bro. Yes.
>> Whoa.
>> A lot of dishonesty in some areas.
>> Yeah.
>> Like did you like talk to him already?
>> Yeah, he's debated he's debated David
Wood. He's debated quite a few others
and he's uh with with lack of better
words, he is uh I'm gonna be as real as
I can. He's a he's a laughingstock of
apologetics right now.
>> Like did he ever like directly engage
either of you two?
there. Yeah, he So, he d he engaged with
Sam Shimone. He engaged with they had
David Wood had a formal debate with him.
I don't know if it was once or twice,
but um yeah, he had a formal debate with
David Wood. He engaged with Sam Shimone
on YouTube, you know.
>> No, but did he engage you, Avery?
>> Oh, me? No. No, I haven't spoken to him.
>> Gotcha. And I I've got debates scheduled
like from now till like February. So,
>> Wow.
>> Yeah. I'm supposed to have a debate on
Tuesday with Abdullah Alanduci
on Rattlesnake TV. So, yeah.
>> All right. Well, hey, uh, Michael,
really cool of you to bring me back onto
your channel, and I'd be more than happy
to study some more and think of some
ways I could refine my explanations and
and you give me some some more new
things to think about. And the next time
I I engage you in a live stream, I'll
just recount what I was to come up with,
and I might come up with something new
up my sleeve. I don't know.
>> I Yeah. Well, I'm still praying for you,
man, and I I hope you are, too. And I
just remember the what when we go
through this stuff, if we catch oursel
making excuses after excuses after
excuses for the text, is the text really
based on truth or we trying to make it
fit the truth. Don't just think about
that for how you go through this stuff
because if you find yourself like let's
say you go away and you start doing
that,
>> okay?
>> Think about how that what that means for
the text and what your beliefs are and
maybe they they need to be changed up or
switched because I've changed up beliefs
I've had because of that.
>> Yeah, I do see where you're going with
that. And and um yeah, and I'll keep you
guys in my prayers, too. And uh hey, uh
Avery, nice meeting you for the first
time.
>> Nice to meet you, too, man.
>> Yeah. And uh maybe see you guys in a
future stream.
>> For sure, bro. Take care of yourself.
Okay.
>> You guys have a good night. Now,
>> bless, man.
>> See, I was last week when I was
streaming, I was like, "Oh, I'm gonna
get some crazy DA guys in here." And
then this guy shows up and he's super
nice.
>> I'm like, "Oh, he's cool. He's chill."
>> I I I watched that. He You guys had a a
great conversation with him.
>> Mhm.
>> He um he thinks he thinks before
speaking and he thinks about what is
being said to him. So that that's what
you can ask for, man, in a conversation,
you know, like this, especially with the
ton of boneheads we get. So
>> they start running the DA script.
>> Yeah. Start running the DA script. Now,
now, by the way, he's also running the
DA. I mean, he took Zacher Nice, you
know, and said, "Here, you know, meet
the challenge." So he he runs the Dawa
script. He just has a better attitude
with it.
Um